so
what'd you think uh
really really good
a rat can move a man's arms and legs but
by what pulling his hair what are you
talking about it's an animated movie
okay what do you expect Dave you guys
liked it that's great teacher's own I
just thought it was a bit of a stretch
yeah even by Pixar standards so funny I
was uh I was just thinking about how
stupid that movie was well we're here I
did yes sir oh and uh don't worry he's
of age too
my hands are out of control what are you
doing I don't know I think a rat is
pulling up my hair and my hair is
directly attached to my limb that's my
beard God damn it you loved up and
that's arguably just as ridiculous as
this houses get lifted into the air by
balloons every year Bill [__] it's three
in the morning what are you doing
what the [__]